local mariachi band is receiving some  well-deserved recognition from the clark  county commissioners today  the band from las vegas high school  performed virtually at president joe  biden's inauguration last month  [Music]  received certificates for their great  work at today's meeting also had a nice  performance there  inauguration was not the first time the  group performed though for president  biden  the students played for him when he  visited las vegas on the campaign trail  last year so that's what you call  going full circle congratulations to  them that's right what an  honor for them and they're so talented  because we've done stories leading up to  the inauguration oh they're absolutely  wonderful  young kids and they sound great i know  nice to see them recognized